thomas bonjour que peut-on d'ores et
déjà retenir de ce forum qui se poursuit
à jérusalem les discours se poursuivent
actuellement avec différents
intervenants qui se succèdent au pupitre
des discours bien souvent plein de
gravité parfois très émouvant les
différents protagonistes de ce forum qui
parfois liste des écrits qui ont été
rédigées par des personnes qui ont vécu
le low cost ont des discours très
émouvant est le premier à avoir pris la
parole aujourd'hui c'est le président
israélien monsieur rivlin qui a eu des
mots lui aussi très fort il a ainsi
déclaré les portes de l'enfer se sont
ouvertes le 27 janvier 1945 le 27
janvier 1945 c'est le jour où l'armée
rouge a libéré le camp d'auschwitz on
retiendra également les mots de vladimir
poutine qui a expliqué que l'union
soviétique avait payé un lourd tribut
avec environ 27 millions de morts
beaucoup de juifs étaient originaires de
l'union soviétique a déclaré le
président russe qui a également pointé
la collaboration de certains pays avec
l'allemagne nazie il faut défendre la
vérité et la justice a déclaré vladimir
poutine le président de la fédération de
russie qui a également soumis une idée
celle d'une réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies cette année
en 2020 est ce la lumière de la réussite
de la coopération des alliés en 1945
une réunion du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies l'idée a été approuvée par
emmanuel macron on écoute les cinq
grandes puissances fondatrice de l'onu
sont garantes du maintien de la
civilisation nous en avons jamais parlé
avec mes homologues et nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord sur deux d'organiser une
réunion des deux cp c'est à dire etats
unis russie chine france et grande
bretagne pour que nous
puissions parler de cela n'importe où
n'importe où et la russie tout à fait
prête à accueillir un tel forum intel
une telle discussion et je vous rejoins
cher vladimir monsieur le président
poutine les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
ont aujourd'hui une responsabilité
historique
je partage votre volonté 75 ans plus
tard de nous rassembler tous ensemble
nous l'avons évoqué il ya quelques jours
et je souhaite que nous puissions le
faire car nous sommes de par cette
histoire est depuis la fin du deuxième
conflit mondial les garants d'un ordre
international qui tient par le droit la
légalité et le respect de chacun au delà
des hommages les discours étaient
parfois très politique ce fut notamment
le cas lorsque benyamin netanyahou le
premier ministre israélien a pris la
parole il a d'abord insisté sur
l'importance de l'armée israélienne et
de ce qu'il qualifie de boucliers un
bouclier contre les menaces et il a
nommé très directement une de ces
menaces il s'agit pour lui de l'iran un
discours repris par les états unis qui
sont représentés cet après midi par le
vice-président américain mike pence on
écoute nous devons encore attendre une
action résolue contre le régime le plus
antisémite qui existent sur la planète
un régime qui cherche ouvertement à
développer des armes nucléaires pour
anéantir l'unique le seul état juif du
clan ces tyrans de téhéran qui
persécuté leur propre peuple qui met en
cause la sécurité de toute la région de
tous les pays du proche orient en et
même du monde entier j'appelle tous les
jours vers demandent à rejoindre cet
effort est essentielle et à faire face à
environ 1900 pire dans ce même esprit
oui mais nous devons aussi rester fort
cet état prévalant d'antisémitisme
contre un gouvernement montrent qui
adopte une étape nier la shoah et qu'ils
voudraient c'est israël de la carte
mondiale est bien le coup et d'israël
doit rester fermes contre la république
terran islamique d'iran voilà pour
quelques déclarations parmi les plus
marquantes de cette après midi les
discours se poursuivre avec notamment
ces montages que vous pouvez apercevoir
derrière moi des montages qui rappelle
la tragique histoire de la seconde
guerre mondiale et de l'holocauste
à noter que dans la salle il y a environ
quarante neuf délégations
internationales mais aussi et c'est
important de le souligner une trentaine
de survivants de la shoah qui assistent
à cette cérémonie
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas à bonaire en direct
due forme forum mondial de la shoah à
jérusalem